This video is sponsored by crunchy roll.
What's up wise?
Crack Jared again.
Today we're covering the only show
guaranteed to traumatize you in its
first 10 minutes.
Goblin slayer.
Now,
while much of the conversation
surrounding the show focuses on that
notorious scene that we're all aware of,
there's something else going on that is
a really interesting development for the
fantasy genre and it all revolves around
the question,
why does Goblin slayer only killed
goblins?
And how does that form the shows greater
message?
Well,
let's bathe in Goblin blood and go deep
in this wise crack condition on Goblin
slayer.
And as always,
spoilers ahead.
Let's kick it off with a quick recap,
a bright eyed priestess.
No one has real names in this show.
And friends set out on their first
adventure,
eager to kill goblins.
But uh,
things go wrong,
very,
very wrong for friends die.
But Goblin slayer rescues her in the
nick of time.
She joins his party and becomes his
Goblin slaying paddle won.
Their party grows when an Elf dwarf and
Lizard man joined them to investigate
some particularly worrisome goblins on
the border.
Then they head off to kill even more
sewer,
goblins,
all the while a demon lord is
threatening the realm and our hero
seriously does not care.
Niac the whole damn damn.
Oh Shit.
That's a good example.
Is Key.
The God,
so today.
Cool,
cool.
Go.
But he like you and I.
Why?
Well,
sure.
There's actual narrative reasons they
killed his sister.
Well,
can you about gun Greece,
but because we like to get Metta,
we wanted to address this question as it
pertains to the genre that the show is
playing.
Fantasy.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's animated,
but the show is pretty heavy on
references to d and D.
There's the dice rolling spell slots,
guilds,
quests,
and a hodgepodge of other fantasy
tropes.
The show relishes in the generics of the
fantasy genre.
Characters and places have intentionally
generic names as the show prefers labels
like Elvin,
ranger watertown or sword maiden.
Even big bosses get nomenclatures like
Goblin champion or demon Lord.
So let's talk about generic fantasy and
novels.
Tabletop games or MMOS heroes start with
the small stuff.
Rats,
bugs,
goblins.
They grind through these small
challenges until they're ready to take
on stronger and more interesting
enemies,
but then some horrifying villain emerges
and threatens the world as you know it.
The story starts with small problems and
builds to a big one,
and once that big one is slane,
then things can go back to being peg.
Goblin slayer steps off that linear path
with a resounding,
you know what?
I'd rather just kill goblins things you
rationalize.
This is choice when his compatriots try
to get them to care about more pressing
matters.
Do you know about the globe edema,
moodle multiples?
You
know,
Chemo Goulburn,
and we'll meet over to you and you know.
See even if the demon Lord dies,
the Goblin slayer argues goblins will
still terrorize rural and vulnerable
areas.
By having our protagonists phobia,
saul on the little guys of sorts,
goblins,
player subverts the basic assumptions of
the fantasy genre,
namely the happily ever after.
Do things go back to normal.
When we've murdered,
the big bad guy has the hero achieved
peace,
not quite eight litany of less
spectacular monster.
Still plague the villagers in the most
recent episode.
The Demon Lords death confirms this
while the constant reference to the
demon Lord earlier in the season would
normally foreshadows some kind of
climactic end of seasons showdown.
So he just say the opposite happens.
The demon Lord is dispatched in under a
minute by some random heroes that we
neither know nor care about,
and instead of suggesting some happily
ever after where instead reminded of
these words from the sword maiden
say the school.
Cool.
So can you pick a Canadian?
We can better understand Goblin slayers
logic.
What's something called theory,
which is pretty much exactly what it
sounds like.
It asks,
what exactly is piece one theorist John
Dalton draws a distinction between two
kinds of peace,
positive and negative.
Negative peace is the absence of war.
It's the kind of piece you're used to
talking about the end of World War II or
the Vietnam war or the civil war.
You get it in the fantasy genre.
We can think of it as the absence of
night canes or sour on organic door I e
o world without the demon lords
destroying the world as we know it.
That's fine and Dandy for peace
theorists,
but it doesn't examine these smaller and
often more pervasive violence that
affects society's most vulnerable
people.
Do I need my job?
Big Deal.
That's where positive piece comes in.
Positive piece is the presence of
justice and protections that serve the
needs of everyone,
more or less what Goblin slayer is
after,
while on the show,
it's simply goblins in the real world.
It can be a litany of this poverty,
famine,
disease,
corruption,
discrimination,
crime,
and so on.
The goblins of the real world,
if you will,
positive piece.
It's especially important for our
understanding of violence.
For many folks,
violence is an interruption to daily
life,
but for some it's the backdrop against
which life takes place.
Goblins,
slayer can't just chill it.
An idyllic farm with cowgirl,
which is really what they call her
without searching for signs of goblins
and fortifying defenses.
Unlike the platinum heroes that killed
the demon.
Lord.
In goblin flavors,
view the shape of the world.
Guarantees that people are on.
Farms will always face gallbladder
attacks.
That's why goblins slayer doesn't care
about the demon.
Lord,
he's busy burning down Goblin this now
that may not seem very peaceful and it's
not,
but it's a question of conflict
prevention and development,
so simply by taking care of the Goblin
problem in the short term,
Goblin slayer starts the process of
longterm protection,
but it's not just that smaller issues
can compound to create an equally crappy
reality.
For many,
the kind of small work that needs to be
done is balked at it's grunt work.
Everyone wants the glory of killing the
demon Lord,
but chopping goblins.
That's child's play.
Even when the demon Lord is gone,
the clean up of his armies is below some
people
ada,
he needed to eat all my money.
I told him,
boy,
he doesn't.
So no,
despite being a silver class adventure
or Goblin slayer is marked for his
choice of missions in the hierarchy of
adventuring.
He's like if general patent started
cleaning latrines,
but in the world of Goblin slayer,
toilets are going uncleaned because
nobody wants to be the janitor,
and without clean toilets we might just
all die from Colorado,
so somebody has to do that work.
We can see this sort of thing all over
the place.
In real life.
People take jobs that get all the glory,
so doctors researching cancer get all
the press while doctors doing routine
work to test the water to prevent
equally deadly stomach illnesses.
Well,
not so much.
People take jobs that are high paying
and high prestigious without much
thought for what?
As the highest social impact.
Even in sports,
everyone wants to be the quarterback.
Nobody wants to be whatever a left
tackle is.
Goblins.
Slayer wanted to kill dragons as a child
and it's not until he sees the dangers
of goblins firsthand that he commits
himself to his mission.
You would just sit and look at q three,
Twenty Coca Cola soda still weeks.
Now,
this is an even bigger problem than it
seems for two reasons.
First,
the stigma against Goblin slang causes
many to minimize the threat goblins
pose.
Slaying Goblins isn't complicated.
You mostly swing swords around and cut
off heads.
They can even apparently get killed by a
strong kick.
Now,
that doesn't mean it's easy as we see
throughout the show,
goblins have tricks of their own that
can make them very dangerous when
they're perceived as a simple problem.
However,
the people sent to deal with the issue
are not qualified because aside from
Goblin slayer,
civil ranked heroes have quote better
things to do,
quarter to sunken meadow bogus I with
them in it,
and that's how you ended up with
situations like this,
so unqualified heroes get murdered and
the goblins stick around.
That sucks,
which leads us to our second issue.
The problem worsens as the goblins breed
and become even more dangerous,
worse yet,
major heroes don't want to get involved
because they think goblins are nothing
but pes or they don't want to admit that
goblins or a real threat because it
would be embarrassing to say so enter
the sword.
Maybe she is the ass kicking.
Super leader of priestesses religion.
She even slayed the original demon Lord
with her big awesome sword.
Is there a name?
She hires Goblins,
slayer and his friends to deal with some
goblins under the city who are
presumably responsible for some murders,
but soon becomes obvious that she
herself committed some light murder to
have the goblins taken care of by
someone else.
That's good.
I could assign a top
because she was afraid after her own
traumatic running and admitting that
you're afraid of goblins after defeating
a demon.
Lord is definitely against the unspoken
hero code.
Goblin attacks can leave people in a
constant state of fear and anxiety.
Those feelings contribute to an already
difficult life for many,
and that again raises the stakes of
positive piece.
Dealing with goblins doesn't necessarily
change the material conditions of life,
but definitely the psychological ones,
goblins slayers.
Intervention to kill the goblins and
talked to the sword maiden about her
fears has a substantial effect on her
wellbeing.
She no longer has goblin nightmares.
You mainly use English 30 minutes.
What's so interesting about this take on
fantasy is what we can expect it will do
to the narrative.
Normally,
as the series goes on,
the threads get bigger and scarier.
We even see this in standalone episodes
when we start off with regular goblins
and then the conflict escalates to an
ogre,
but since the demon Lord has already
gotten snowed ears,
your toes and the goblins slayers and
10th on only slaying goblins.
What creative ways will they come up
with to up the stakes?
Perhaps we'll see more ambiguity
regarding the Goblin threat with this
false sense of security taking hold
across the land.
The goblin problem will probably remain
in obscurity for most,
but as we saw at the end of the last
episode,
it's about to hit Goblin slayer much
closer to home.
So is the story.
You're gonna stay on Goblins or are we
cruising toward a collision with
something?
Sure and batter.
Well,
you can find out if we're right about
the shows trajectory for free on crunchy
roll or you can upgrade to add free hd
by going to crunchy roll.com/wise
crack and getting a 30 day free trial.
You can watch goblins slayer these
second it comes out.
You'll also be able to enjoy their
animate catalog of 30,000
episodes from their other popular
seasonal titles like that time I got
reincarnated as a slime or black clover
to catalog favorites,
including one piece Berserk and my
personal favorite anime,
full metal alchemist,
brotherhood.
Once again,
that's crunchy.
Roll Dot com slash wise crack or click
the link in the description below for 30
days.
Add free hd anime content.
Thanks again for watching.
We got some great videos coming up in
the new year,
including an episode on mob psycho,
100 Avatar,
the last airbender and maybe another
episode that comments on the season
finale of Goblin slayer.
As always,
thanks for watching guys pee.